>>> THIS JUST IN TO CNN DONALD
TRUMP SAYS HE PLEADED THE FIFTH
NEW YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL HE
LETITIA JAMES.
THAT HAPPENED THIS MORNING.
SHE AND HER TEAM ARE
INVESTIGATING THE FINANCES OF
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION.
>> AND HE IS FACING MANY LEGAL
WOES THIS WEEK.
THERE'S ALSO THE APPEALS COURT
THAT RULED THAT HOUSE LAWMAKERS
CAN GET THEIR HANDS ON HIS TAX
RETURNS.
A JUDGE RULED HIS FORMER
ATTORNEY RUDY GIULIANI TO
TESTIFY TO A GEORGIA JURY FOR
HIS SCHEME TO OVERTURN THE 2020
ELECTION.
WEF BEEN LEARNING NEW DETAILS
ABOUT THE FBI SEARCH AT HIS
MAR-A-LAGO RESIDENCE IN FLORIDA.
>> LET'S PICK UP WHERE WE LEFT
OFF AND ABBY PHILIP I LEFT YOU
TO GET TO THE IMPORTANT SIGNING
AT THE WHITE HOUSE AND THERE IS
NEWS FROM THE FORMER PRESIDENT
EXPLAINING WHY HE PLEADED THE
FIFTH AND IT'S IMPORTANT CONTEXT
BECAUSE WE'LL ALL REMEMBER IN
2016 AS IT PERTAINED TO THE
INVESTIGATION OF HILLARY
CLINTON'S E-MAILS HE SAID IF
YOU'RE INNOCENT WHY ARE YOU
TAKING THE FIFTH.
NOW HE SAYS IN THIS STATEMENT,
ABBY, I ONCE ASKED IF YOU'RE
INNOCENT WHY ARE YOU TAKING THE
FIFTH.
NOW I KNOW THE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION, THE FORMER PRESIDENT
WRITES WHEN YOUR FAMILY, COMPANY
AND ALL OF THE PEOPLE IN YOUR
ORBIT HAVE BECOME THE TARGET OF
A POLITICALLY-MOTIVATED WITCH
HUNT YOU HAVE NO CHOICE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS?
>> FIRST OF ALL, THIS IS VERY
MUCH RELATED TO THE EARLIER
CONVERSATION AND THE ARGUMENT
MR. TRUMP IS MAKING IS THAT HE
IS BEING TARGETED POLITICALLY
FROM ALL SIDES AND THAT'S THE
CASE HE'S MAKING TO HIS BASE TO
ENGENDER EVEN MORE SUPPORT AND
THIS PLAYS INTO THAT.
JUST A QUICK NOTE BECAUSE AS YOU
WERE READING THAT PART OF
TRUMP'S STATEMENT IT DID REMIND
ME OF THE FACT THAT HILLARY
CLINTON, IN ALL OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS THAT SHE WAS
INVOLVED IN THAT TRUMP HIMSELF
SAID SHE SHOULD HAVE BEEN LOCKED
UP FOR DID TESTIFY PUBLICLY AND
PRIVATELY ON THESE MATTERS.
TRUMP, ON THE OTHER HAND HAS
TRIED REALLY AGGRESSIVELY TO
AVOID BEING UNDER OATH IN THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND THIS IS JUST
THE LATEST CASE OF THAT.
>> DAVID, LET'S PICK UP ON THAT.
IT'S NOT JUST PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND HIS FAMILY CALLING THIS A
WITCH HUNT AND YOU HAVE TOP
REPUBLICANS AND LAWMAKERS WHO
ARE SAYING THAT THESE SERIES OF
EVENTS FROM THE FBI SEARCH TO
HIS DEPOSITION TODAY WHICH HE
ANSWERED NO QUESTIONS AND NOW
POSSIBLY CONGRESS GETTING HIS
TAX RECORDS.
HOW -- WHAT CAN BE DONE, DO YOU
THINK TO CONVINCE SO MANY
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS THAT ALL
OF THIS IS LAWFUL, THAT IT'S NOT
A WITCH HUNT?
>> HE'S GOING TO HAVE -- THIS IS
SO ENTANGLING AND IT'S HARD TO
SORT IT ALL OUT, BUT EARLIER
THIS WEEK THAT THE FBI AGENTS
SWEPT INTO MAR-A-LAGO AND GOT
ALL OF THIS INFORMATION OUT AND
EVERYTHING LIKE THAT, ONE HAD
THE FEELING THAT THE GOVERNMENT
WAS DOING SOMETHING THAT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE FOR EVERYBODY ELSE TO
DO AND THAT WAS CREATE DONALD
TRUMP AS A SYMPATHETIC FIGURE.
SUDDENLY HE LOOKED LIKE HE WAS
BEING DONE IN BY ALL THESE
FORCES AND NOW WHEN HE GOES AND
TAKES THE FIFTH, YOU KNOW, HE'S
BACK TO WHO HE WAS, VERY
UNSYMPATHETIC AND VERY MUCH SHOW
ME, TELL ME THE TRUTH ABOUT WHAT
YOU'RE DOING AND I THINK HE'S
MISPLAYED HIS HAND AND MAYBE IT
WILL PROVIDE TEMPORARY
PROTECTION FOR SOME OF HIS
PEOPLE, BUT IN THE END HE'LL
HAVE TO COME CLEAN IN ONE
ENVIRONMENT OR ANOTHER AND IT
WOULD BE SO MUCH STRONGER IF HE
COULD TELL US WHAT'S GOING ON,
NOT ONLY IN MAR-A-LAGO, BUT
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THESE OTHER
FRONTS SO THAT THE COUNTRY COULD
MAKE A JUDGEMENT, A BALANCED
JUDGMENT.
IT'S VERY HARD TO MAKE BALANCED
JUDGMENTS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
BECAUSE HE SURPRISES YOU
FREQUENTLY, I'M AFRAID ON THE
DOWN SIDE.
JOINING US NOW ON ALL OF THIS IS
DAVID K. JOHNSTON WHO HAS
COVERED DONALD TRUMP FOR MORE
THAN THREE YEARS.
ANALYST PHIL MUDD IS A SENIOR
FBI INTELLIGENCE OFFICER AND
JENNIFER ROGERS, A FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
JENNIFER, LET'S START WITH THE
DEPOSITION TODAY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THE
STATEMENT PUT OUT BY THE
PRESIDENT, UNDER THE ADVICE OF
MY COUNSEL AND FOR ALL OF THE
ABOVE REASONS, I'VE DECLINED TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS PRESENTED
TO HIM TODAY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT?
>> WELL, THIS WAS THE MILLION
DOLLAR QUESTION, KATE, WHETHER
HE WAS GOING TESTIFY OR NOT.
HIS SON ERIC DID TAKE THE FIFTH
OVER 500 TIMES AND DON JUNIOR
DID TESTIFY AND IVANKA DID
TESTIFY.
WHAT DON SENIOR WOULD TESTIFY
AND TAKE THE FIFTH.
HIS STATEMENTS NOW WON'T BE IN
THE RECORD.
THEY CAN'T BE USED IN A CRIMINAL
CASE OR THE CIVIL CASE, BUT IT
ALSO COMES WITH CONSEQUENCES
BECAUSE TISH JAMES IN HER CIVIL
CASE IF SHE FILES ONE CAN USE
THE FACT THAT HE PLEADED THE
FIFTH AND HIS ANSWERS WOULD HAVE
BEEN HARMFUL TO HIM.
THIS IS WHAT HE'S DONE.
IT'S PROBABLY THE SAFER COURSE,
GIVEN THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS INTO HIM, BUT YOU
KNOW, YOU HAVE TO GO BACK TO THE
BASICS AND SAY IF YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO HIDE AND IF YOUR
TESTIMONY WOULD HAVE BEEN TRUTH
F
TRUTHFUL AND WOULD NOT HAVE HURT
YOU THERE WAS NO REASON TO TAKE
THE FIFTH AND IT'S IN RESPECT TO
HIS BUSINESS PRACTICES THAT
THERE WERE REASONS THAT HE DID
NOT WANT TO TESTIFY TRUTH LEVEL
ABOUT THEM.
>> YOU ARE MENTIONING THE
CRIMINAL CASE AND I'M WONDERING
WHAT THIS DEPOSITION COULD
POTENTIALLY MEAN FOR THE
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION BY THE
NEW YORK CITY DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
>> IT DOESN'T MEAN MUCH NOW
BECAUSE HE HASN'T ACTUALLY
TESTIFIED.
I KNOW THE D.A. ALVIN BRAGG HAS
BEEN WATCHING TISH JAMES'
INVESTIGATION.
THEY'VE BEEN COORDINATING ON
THEIR INVESTIGATIONS.
IF HE HAD TESTIFIED I BELIEVE
THE PROSECUTORS IN BRAGG'S
OFFICE WOULD HAVE CAREFULLY
COMBED OVER THAT TESTIMONY TO
SEE WHETHER ANY OF IT
DEMONSTRATED EVIDENCE OF
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY THAT THEY
COULD CHARGE, BUT NOW THAT HE
HAS REFUSED TO TESTIFY IT
DOESN'T GIVE THEM ANYTHING
ADDITIONAL TO WORK WITH.
>> DAVID, HOW MUCH IS AT STAKE
FOR DONALD TRUMP'S BUSINESS WITH
ALL OF THIS?
>> WELL, UNDER NEW YORK STATE
LAW, LETITIA JAMES COULD HAVE
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION PUT OUT
OF BUSINESS.
YOU HAVE A RIGHT TO YOUR LIFE,
BUT A CORPORATION DOES NOT HAVE
A RIGHT TO ITS LIFE.
THAT'S THE WORST SCENARIO
PROBABLY FOR DONALD TRUMP
BEYOND, YOU KNOW, WHETHER
TESTIMONY HE MIGHT HAVE GIVEN
COULD HAVE BEEN USED ASHGAINST M
AND OTHER PROSECUTORS.
>> DOES IT SURPRISE YOU AT ALL
THAT HE'S NOT ANSWERING
QUESTIONS.
>> DONALD HAS AN UTTER CONTEMPT
FOR THE LAW.
HE BELIEVES HE'S SPECIAL.
HE'S USED DELAY AND AVOIDANCE
TACTICS HIS ENTIRE CAREER.
HE COULD HAVE SAID A LONG TIME
AGO, I'LL TAKE THE FIFTH
AMENDMENT IF QUESTIONED ABOUT
ANYTHING, BUT HE'S TRIED TO DRAG
THESE THINGS OUT HOPING TO
BENEFIT FROM THINGS LIKE
STATUTES OF LIMITATIONS.
>> PHIL, TO THE OTHER
INVESTIGATION, THE FBI SEARCH OF
TRUMP'S RESIDENCE, THE FBI
SAYING CNN'S REPORTING THAT THE
REASON THEY WENT IN IS THAT THEY
THOUGHT THAT THERE WAS -- THAT
THERE WAS A CONCERN THAT FROM
DONALD TRUMP OR HIS TEAM THAT
THEY DID NOT RETURN ALL OF THE
DOCUMENTS THAT HAD BEEN TAKEN
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU THINK THERE MUST BE MORE
HERE THAN A MISPLACED,
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENT FOR THE FBI
TO GO IN, THOUGH.
TELL ME WHY.
>> I SPENT 25 YEARS LOOKING AT
CLASSIFIED --
>> HOLD ON, DAVID.
GO AHEAD, PHIL.
>> I'M SORRY.
I SPENT 25 YEARS LOOKING AT
TOP-SECRET STUFF FROM 7:00 A.M.
TO 7:00 P.M.
TOP SECRET STUFF SOUNDS SEXY
OUTSIDE WASHINGTON AND THOSE
DOCUMENTS ARE A DIME A DOZEN
AROUND THE CITY AND I GUARANTEE
YOU THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO WILL
TAKE HOME A CLASSIFIED DOCUMENT
TO READ BECAUSE THEY DON'T GET
TIME TO READ IT IN THE OFFICE.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT'S
APPROPRIATE.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT IS LEGAL.
I'M SAYING THAT IS COMMON.
OCCASIONAL ABUSE OF THOSE
DOCUMENTS, I WOULD SAY LIKE IT
OR NOT, IS PROBABLY RELATIVELY
COMMON.
YOU HAVE TO MENTION THAT WITH
ANOTHER PIECE AND THAT IS TWO
VERY QUIET BUREAUCRATS, THAT IS
THE FBI DIRECTOR AND ATTORNEY
GENERAL WHO ARE TRYING TO KEEP
THEIR AGENCIES OUT OF THE
LIMELIGHT BY NOT SPEAKING, ALL
OF A SUDDEN DECIDE TO AUTHORIZE
WITH THE FEDERAL JUDGE THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT -- ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT SEARCHS THE FBI HAS
EVER DONE, TO FIND SOME
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS?
>> THOSE TWO PIECES, THE FACTS
THAT THESE DOCUMENTS WOULD BE
COMMON AND ATTORNEY GENERAL AND
THE DIRECTOR CAME OUT OF THE
SHADOWS, TELL ME SOMETHING ELSE
IS AFOOT AND IF THEY ARE SUPER
SECRET.
I NEED TO KNOW WHAT THEY ARE AND
I'M NOT SURE THAW CHASED
MAR-A-LAGO TO FIND THAT STUFF.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKES OF THE
PRESSURE TO COME OUT AND SPEAK
PUBLICLY ABOUT WHAT THIS WAS ALL
ABOUT LIKE WHEN I WAS TALK
PEREZ.
>> I WOULD BE SUPER CAUTIOUS.
THERE ARE A COUPLE OF PROBLEMS
WITH COMING OUT TO SPEAK AND
THAT IS THE SUBJECT OR TARGET
LIKE DONALD TRUMP.
HE SORT OF LET THE CAT OUT OF
THE BAG.
WHAT DO YOU SAY NOW?
I WOULD STILL BE CAUTIOUS IF I
WERE THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
FIRST, HE'S A PRIVATE CITIZEN.
KATE, LET'S MAKE YOU THE SUBJECT
OF AN INVESTIGATION.
WHEN THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE,
IF THAT WERE TO HAPPEN -- I HOPE
NOT, WOULD YOU FEEL COMFORTABLE
WITH THAT EVEN WITH THEM SAYING
WHY YOU'RE UNDER INVESTIGATION
OR WHY YOUR HOUSE WERE SEARCHED
PEOPLE WILL ASSUME YOU DID
SOMETHING WRONG AND YOU PUT THE
PRIVATE CITIZEN UNDER A
LIMELIGHT AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE HAS TO BE CAUTIOUS ABOUT
DOING THAT.
LET'S CLOSE WITH THE JAMES COMEY
EXAMPLE.
AS SOON AS THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE SPEAKS, DID YOU CLOSE
THE INVESTIGATION?
DID YOU CLOSE THE INVESTIGATION?
WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO CLOSE IT?
AS SOON AS YOU OPEN THAT DOOR
YOU HAVE TO KEEP SPEAKING
BECAUSE YOU'VE TOLD PEOPLE WE'LL
UPDATE YOU ON AN INVESTIGATION.